what where do you get these questions
hi I'm Tim Allen and I'm a Gemini what I
do is my cars I try to make lesser
people feel terrible about their lives
we bought this an episode of home
improvement from Jay Leno played a
character that I saw that episode and
his jumpsuit yeah yeah a bad actor it
hasn't gotten any better I saw that I
knew it's just downhill from there with
Jay oh it's old career it's just it's
over for him look here's what you do
it's it's a smash box no synchros up or
down you try to find the gear go like
this and hang us up that's you get like
three okay that's it Jay - get in these
cars new and just sit if you saw me
undress you go whoa what are women
missing
shizzle like a rock six packs kegs I got
every every acronym for liquor built
there come this way
what happens if you get near 200
horsepower in a Volkswagen yeah what
happens what happens is you have a
engine that barely fits in the engine
compartment and it's clearly closed
undriveable did you get yourself on
Mulholland Drive boy this is pass and
you're this close to the windshield and
you're going and I'm in a Volkswagen
this would be one of those what was tim
thinking as they pull me out of the
wreckage so here it says what am i doing
now hand-built this hand-built the
bumpers it's curious
not an airport anywhere near here don't
try look out there's a hole there's a
pit of snakes so I see this in an in
another car magazines and there's a guy
in Pennsylvania he rebuilt everything
and he I just was a my dad worked for
the company there's five of these first
sleeper that Studebaker made I'm just I
was shocked at the picture so I had to
have it the guys that drove these must
have said good boy are we living now cuz
they drove those trucks have had the
open fronts yeah there was just one step
away from come on yeah this has a
sleeper in it and my little kid and I
think this is the most fun
no she she's four and we can't there's
only four year-olds can get this close
to your head they don't think that's
weird and just thinking that's where the
kids have no what is that spatial thing
like you know we don't want to do this
you know there's something wrong here is
that a real camera I click robots and
sci-fi stuff and cell phones
I got antique cell phones I had a little
girl in here one of my but one of my
guys daughters he says what's wrong with
you that's that's her response to this
so I fired him and sent her home
Buzz Lightyear see I always put Buzz
ahead of woody because I got a better
stay and literally built better than
woody let me look out he's got look at
the legs
they're made of fabric no crotch I
actually have a crotch you know that's
that's very important to me Tim thank
you so much
perfect
to see more episodes of car collectors
subscribe to GQ calm
son of